let's let's jump to the story you
mentioned luke we got here from the
daily caller
ken cuccinelli claims pelosi asked for
crew
manned machine guns in washington
i believe it i i kind of believe it but
we'll let's read
acting deputy homeland security
secretary ken cuccinelli told fox news
the story
tuesday that house speaker nancy pelosi
asked for crew manned machine guns to be
part of security forces in washington dc
ahead of president-elect joe biden's
inauguration cuccinelli and anchor
martha mccallum were discussing the
presence of 25 000 national guard troops
the nation's capital
after pro-trump rioters stormed the u.s
capitol building january 6.
a division cuccinelli said responding to
mccallum's assertion that the number of
troops is greater than the number in
afghanistan and iraq
you have a division the last up of
thousands of these troops was requested
by the speaker
through the capitol police she even
wanted crew-manned machine guns in
washington
that was rejected because there's simply
no use for that in a security
arrangement
for a civilian undertaking just so some
of this has gone beyond
any legitimate security need cuccinelli
defended the troops as disciplined and
professional
and said they will perform as expected
but added that the state capitol
building
buildings are also important to defend
the world is not about washington he
said
it's supposed to be about everywhere
else which is what the department of
homeland security tries to keep secure
the acting dhs deputy secretary
confirmed that threats of individual
attacks in different places
are also absolutely a problem before
criticizing those who focus
only on dc he says at the same time
where was the concern for the rest of
america
congressmen aren't more important than
any other american it's a good point
boom and everyone in this country should
should be kept safe and that's what the
department of homeland security has
endeavored to do
through this entire difficult year crew
manned machine guns what would that be
like full auto 50 bmg
there's a team where one's holding it
the other one has to carry the ammo and
make sure the belt yeah the belt what
does that would that be 50 bmg
i guess theoretically there's many
different calibers yeah you could do
seven machine guns
yes so uh i'd like to imagine they were
like mounting 50 bmg just like
like like nancy pelosi wanted just like
to like if a human being gets hit one
by one of those things they explode
right like a red mist i wouldn't want to
see that
i don't i think a lot of soldiers dark
humor
but i want to make a point i'm just
trying to drive home how insane
it sounds but here's the thing in 2017
when there were thousands of people in
dc riding and smashing everything and
starting fires
they organized that protest for hillary
clinton not for donald trump
the original plan was that hillary
clinton was going to be inaugurated and
they were going to go in riot
trump won and they said well we're still
going to riot so i wonder if
the real fear here wasn't the the
specter of the far right
which typically doesn't do anything but
that they knew
like we saw in portland and seattle and
denver and a few other places
antifa would have come out in dc and
destroyed everything were it not for the
national guard
yeah and i remember being there in dc
you were there too i think yeah
we all got pepper sprayed i was
temporarily arrested and then talked my
way out of it with my press credentials
but it was a wild crazy day with a lot
of property destruction we were we were
walking down the street during the riot
while we were running with the riot
and then the police set up a line you
charged through it
and then i getting pepper sprayed
heavily they sprayed you like they
sprayed
their faces he ran through the line yeah
and then i went into the doorway of this
building
and then because this is how it works
everyone followed me
and so then i was smashed up against the
door by a bunch of antifa and they were
and some of the people were nice they
gave me uh the milk of magnesia or
whatever mailbox
for the pepper spray i i was told three
times by the
supervisor that i was arrested and not
free to go yep but eventually
a local news crew had their boss had
called saying you better not arrest our
crew
so when he pulled out this crew i
reminded the lieutenant that i was like
hey i talked to you look here's my press
card and he was like come on
and a bunch of journalists got pulled
out now here's the funny thing about
this
i get pulled out and i tweet just got
arrested they released me before you
know being taken
i was there for like an hour or two and
some other journalists did get arrested
and they were so mad they were tweeting
like i got arrested
i'm like dude one guy was screaming at
the top of his lungs at the cops you
mother effort
you can arrest me and i was like i'm
terribly sorry officer i'm a journalist
do your job on you know here's my press
card just come and talk to me when you
get a chance yeah and that was it i
remember seeing the kettle and i'm like
oh my god they're going to kill
arrest everyone and there's a wall of
pepper spray and they were spraying it
and i was like i'm just going to run
right through it i got hit really hard
there was another female reporter
who just made up and said i'm pregnant
i'm pregnant i was like i'm going i'm
going through this and then luckily
they pulled around and get hit yeah they
pulled her out but back to the point of
machine guns that
nancy pelosi wants she's essentially
saying protection
for me but not for thee these are
anti-gun
anti-second amendment individuals who
don't believe in you having the right
for personal protection
but they want machine guns for
themselves are you kidding me
you've got the nfa you can't make was it
how does it work you can't make a
machine gun you can't have a machine
you could only have machine guns within
a certain year so so pretty much machine
guns are only available for the super
rich that could afford them because
there's a limited supply within a
certain year that you can
uh it could could have them so they're
grandfathered in there's few remaining
uh and the few that are are only
available to people who could spend
twenty thirty forty fifty thousand
dollars for government or the military
yes so nancy pelosi is leading the
charge to take away your right to have
these
this protection but she wants of all
things if she said i would like the
national guard to be armed with with
assault rifles i'd be like yeah well of
course the politicians get to carry guns
the politicians get to have security but
she she well but think about it room and
machine guns but they're loving but
they're
practical when you're talking about crew
men machine guns during inaugurations
during big events when there's crowds
this is the least tactical weapon that
you could have especially in big cities
with big crowds because you're going to
mow down a whole bunch of innocent
civilians
standing in the way that don't deserve
to be killed buildings yeah so it's just
absolutely illogical it's not listening
to thinking by nancy pelosi it's because
they don't understand that full auto
isn't tactical they think we have to ban
full semi-automatic weapons which for
one that they've actually said that
means nothing
when they say uh i remember at the march
for our lives people were like you know
no one needs a full
fully automatic weapon and i'd tell them
like well you can't buy one
and nobody has one except for like this
really rare grandfathered and old
and it's never used in a crime here yeah
nobody's carrying around
a light machine gun in their truck or
whatever to like like it's a movie or
something
right but that's what these people think
so here's what people don't realize
now i'm sure people can correct me if
i'm wrong but what what you should be
worried about my understanding is that a
semi-auto is actually way more dangerous
than a full auto for a deranged killer
because they'll spray off all their ammo
and miss and then click click click
whereas with semi-auto they can go one
two very you know
calm and precise but more importantly
when you have the military it's
sometimes better to do select
to to do you know semi-auto or burst
fire than full auto
nancy pelosi saying crew man to machine
guns shows they don't actually know
how to operate a weapon why and and what
kind of weapon you would need
for this certain circumstances so she's
should never be president she doesn't
understand military she
she wanted the dod was it to go
take do a coup against trump like two
weeks ago she asked them to strip trump
from the chain of commerce
well she has no considerations for the
citizens of washington d.c
think about it it's much more nefarious
than that i think because
this um this was in reaction to what
happened on the sixth okay
say with you about the six but we're in
a country here where
pretty much anybody can get a firearm
pretty much anybody can get an ar an
assault weapon anything like that
i don't remember seeing a whole lot of
protesters
brandishing much less firing firearms in
the sixth
so if this was a preparation for a
reaction similar this reaction was in
preparation for what they saw in the six
which is calling for is automatic
military weapons to be used on an
unarmed population these
this is what she thinks of the country
of the people of the citizens
she is content with having 50 caliber
military-grade weapons
aimed at them and ready we added the 50
caliber part oh
okay all right all right all right oh
this is oh you're right you've got
room and machine guns yes the guns that
require multiple people to operate them
let's
go with that that's what she thinks of
us in the country
i'm surprised she didn't set up
landmines all over the capitol building
i mean
it would make more sense with the you
know actual tactical
defensive positioning rather than mowing
people down with automatic machine guns
so it's
but it's beyond the people could you
imagine look look i was i've been i've
been to ukraine i know i mentioned
ukraine a lot because this
place i've been to and there are still
buildings riddled with bullet holes
from world war ii and cold war conflict
and so i'm walking down the street we
went to the mall we get food and then my
friend is like oh look at that building
see all those holes yeah that's this
machine gun fire
and i'm like they never fixed it no i'm
like wow i mean it's a poor country so
they're kind of just like
what are we gonna do about it right and
remember under her leadership in the
leaders
of her party we had members of in our
navy in hostile ports being ordered not
to be armed not to have uh
ammunition in their firearms taking
their naval vessels into hostile ports
and they were attacked and many of them
died from that
yet here at this inauguration she wants
what's the situation with the naval guy
i haven't heard of this what happened oh
yeah it was under the uh previous
democrat administration
um they were prevented from having uh
armed weapons as they went into several
um
you know hostile uh uh ports
and there was one case where that
actually ended up um an attack ship came
in they were unable to respond to it
and it detonated and killed a bunch of
american sailors do you know where that
was
i'm sure we can google it or look it up
i can't recall somewhere in the middle
east that was
that was pelosi's well it was that was
when she was in congress and her
democratic party's leadership
they had the white house at the time so
there you go you can see what these
people what these politicians think of
the people
and what they would do to them but
that's a good point man the people who
stormed the capitol many of them were
just bewildered and befuddled walking
into open doors
some of them were violent and aggressive
but they were i think the worst we saw
was crowbars
yeah well i think there was one video
with one guy brandishing what looked
like a firearm
with within his shirt but i don't think
he took it out and was waving it around
but
i think it's fair to say that the
magnitude of the threat was
widely exaggerated for political
purposes and political powers and also
for the media for
ratings views clicks with their kind of
fear-mongering sensationalism
that drove the headlines in and now we
have some violence happening they don't
care about it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you